Angela what would you say is the easiest
part of making this film Romeo misses a
payment what's been the easiest part of
this whole process we know filmmaking is
especially daunting in post but what's
been the most a burlas excuse me the
most effortless you know I thought about
that I think it takes me back when we
first started that we didn't have a
direction as opposed to we just wanted
to get as much footage as possible we
started with 220 hours of footage the
first cut was 96 minutes and then we
said we're going to bring it down to 66
minutes to really get as much of the
information as we can in this film and I
think that we didn't have a transcript
we didn't have any buddy sitting there
telling us what the voice was but for
some reason I always remembered the
stories and it was like let's go back to
this person and I think what was easy
for me was to relate to the people we
were interviewing and I could use their
sound bites and and and it was it kind
of made the movie flow it's weird that
we filmed somebody you know like on
Tuesday for the first time and he ended
up ending the movie you know six years
later it was just I think it was really
a miracle the way it happened the way
it's set up I just felt like I had to
just keep showing up and somehow it was
going to work itself out so you did not
flush out a treatment you didn't have an
actual beginning middle and end before
you know we wrote I wrote down maybe
four pages of what the film was going to
be in the title and I just called up my
buddy and said have we have to figure
this out and that our first flight was
to Dallas because we're really going to
Dallas I go yeah we've got this approval
we need to go and it just became you
know then we went to New York and we got
more interviews
you